Ubisoft and Nintendo have always had a
strong relationship an uber soft CEO Eve
Gil mo has now spoken about that support
and shared some of his thoughts on
Nintendo's upcoming NX I'm Lucy and
welcome to your we're better together
gamespot news update suree Ubisoft
presentation attended by gamespot kill
Moe discuss disruptions in the hardware
business which there are quite a few
right now with the new xbox one and
playstation 4 systems the Nintendo NX +
0 vr regarding the NX he said the new
Nintendo is a fantastic machine it's
really a new approach it's really
Nintendo coming with something new again
we love it we spoke with Gil mo after
the event and he expressed concern with
the agility and ability to take risks it
would lose if vivendi's hostile takeover
moves forward a game like zombie you an
original game for the unproven Wii U
console seems like a prime example of
the kind of thing it was only able to do
because it was an independent company
earth to elaborate on why Ubisoft has
such faith in Nintendo he reiterated
what he said earlier about the effect
new systems have on consumers he
explains what we see is players are more
open when new hardware is coming so we
have the chance to come with something
we have never done before because we
know that if we are the first there
people will try our game and maybe we'll
be able to get into that new genre as
our people wanted to do a game like
zombie you they were happy they could
just use the wii u to do it for us a
machine is a tool of expression but when
everything becomes stable it's less open
to innovation we always want innovation
for us we know opportunities to try
something new are a lot more rewarding
when it's in new machines tnx is set to
launch by the end of March 2017 the
excited for nintendo's new console or
are you overwhelmed by all these new
console developments let me know in the
comments below or come by me on Twitter
I met Lucy James games for all things
super soft and for all things NX make
sure
keep it gamespot